probably one of the toughest teammates
I've ever had
lose Johnson how you doing my man I'm
good
excellent first of all your jacket was
so flying yesterday I just need to fret
just send me this watch
send me the swash of it you got it what
color was the pants dark grey see the
difference between you and I mousse you
will comment down with the pants I would
have had the pants to match the jacket
that's the only difference between you
are there and I appreciate our last
lunch gathering very interesting and I
owe you one now I got to bring you over
to the hood so you can eat with me so we
can have a good time I know you're not
scared of that because you all love that
you embody that and I appreciate you man
we got to get down to football man it's
a lot going on and Cleveland right now
what do you think about this it's tough
it's tough like every time you have a
change like that in season you know the
players are resilient they want to win
obviously we want to change like this is
maybe there's something there's
something wrong inside that that only
the people inside know about so as you
moves then we love the lane there you go
you know that to me is the most
important thing so you know you're going
to you're going to get close but you're
never getting over the top so if you're
in that situation and we've seen it
again here to start the season and 2018
so that to me was one of the biggest
reasons that a change was necessary
well necessary so you saying you
advocate of the firing of their head
coach but as well as you know Todd Haley
as well so I'm asking with that sense of
urgency who's gonna call the place yeah
yeah well has everything been final the
last I heard was to be meeting here
shortly a staff meeting here shortly to
kind of map out the plan going forward
so I mean obviously Todd Haley does have
head coaching experience in his
background but not a very successful
stint it can
the city also hearing did I that I've
heard al Sandra's name being mentioned
which you know under the circumstances
with the personalities of Todd Haley and
Greg Williams might be the best the best
option for Cleveland in that situation
well I'm hearing did Todd Haley get
fired as well yeah yes correct
so Todd Haley got fired as well moose
Wow I'm saying who's gonna call the
plays in how a ruff is debt to fire two
men simultaneously it don't make sense
to me it seems like it's a debacle
you're not you have no game plan to move
forward because this was so impromptu I
don't know if something blew up with
Haley but we're guesstimating right now
but it's just indicative of the type of
organization the Browns have been over
the last decade exactly right that may
be the most important point we walk away
from this whole discussion with is it
seems like nothing has changed in
Cleveland you know whether it's the
inability to to get some stability at
the quarterback position the inability
to get stability from the head coaching
position the inability to create a
direction moving forward you know that
that just seems to be the common cause
here and you bring in a head coach and
Hugh Jackson with an offensive
background and then you bring in an
offensive coordinator to kind of change
things up and as you point out you say
goodbye to both so you know where does
that leave you with the number one
overall pick and address in the future I
mean he I mean he has no idea what's
coming so you know unfortunately I just
you know some of these franchises seem
to be a little bit snake bit and you
know Cleveland you know I think
everybody hoped that Jon Gruden was
gonna fix what's going on in Oakland but
you can see with all the changes that's
going on out there that that's going to
be a very difficult transition and I
don't know and and I thought you know
i'm a big John Dorsey fan I I thought
that maybe the stability that he would
bring to the personnel department in the
front office area would start to trickle
into the staff and towards the back of
the building but it appears that that
that's not going to be the case here in
the first year Deion Sanders and Aramis
Johnson filled in for Rich Eisen who's
coming back from
Londyn having a wonderful conversation
about the NFL
let's talk cowboys real briefly because
I don't want to spend a lot of time
because they're not playoff team right
now so I never really spent a lot of
time on teams that I don't feel like
it's going to the playoffs we got people
that really want to place an assessment
a sim Garrett get chasing out get
chasing out and and I'm a little
different not just because he's our
former teammate but just because it's
not a lot to work with personnel-wise I
see offensively out outside the numbers
yeah you just went in you you made a
trade and you're gonna bring in a
receiver which to atone for not getting
Kevin really on draft day but when we
here get Jason out of there do this
I've never hear them talking about the
person who was responsible for acquiring
the talent in Wilma clay or B me that
that seems to be one of the big so to me
this is a team that walked in the Travis
Frederick injury when the diagnosis of
GRA syndrome was was a huge impact to
this team they thought they had the left
guard position sorted out via the draft
that that has not proven to be true
right now the offensive line is not the
offensive line that it was three years
ago true two years ago and this is a
this is an offense built around that
offensive line I think going into the
season bringing in Sanjay Lao and and
and hoping that he would be able to
elevate the play I thought they brought
in some good wide receivers I like the
anti Thompson you know the the you know
Allen Hurns
you know they seem to bring in some good
guys and you're hoping that they all
kind of rise to the occasion there was
not a true number one there but we've
seen other teams do wide receiver by
committee and it's just not working for
Dallas right now and I think the main
reason is that offensive line is not
playing to the level that they play that
in the past that allowed Izzy keel to
run the way that he did that opened up
things for dak Prescott down the field
because you had to commit extra people
in the box to stop the running game
I don't feel like people think they have
to do that anymore I think they feel
comfortable with 7:00 and and they're
able to they're able to play the defense
that they want to play you know Dallas
is not dictating anything right
offensively and when they had success
they had the ability to dictate to the
opposition well two teams that can
dictate are the Saints in the Rams and I
cannot wait to be a fan this weekend I
cannot wait to see this game it's too
profound quarterbacks going at it to
defenses they got some holes and all
both offenses can't exploit but how do
you see this game playing out this
coming weekend I think it's just like
you if I'm gonna be a fan for this one
we've had New Orleans a couple of times
this season we had them against
Baltimore a couple of weeks ago and they
did some things that nobody had done to
Baltimore up until that point you know
Baltimore had not allowed a second-half
touchdown all season long and and with
the game on the line the moorlands was
able to sustain to drive through
touchdowns the end of the third and
beginning of the fourth quarter
they're not the team that we used to
think they were when it was Drew Brees
in the passing game with Mark Ingram
with Kamara this is a very unique very
dynamic team and they really stress
defenses and then that defense has been
really the reason that that New Orleans
always had to be so good offensively it
was always a shootout they were always
trying to keep pace with their opponent
because their defense
you know wouldn't hold up well that
defense is vastly improved and maybe a
stumble they had the first couple of
weeks they've gotten that wreck they've
gotten that remedied and Dennis Allen's
group is playing very very well it's a
very good front they've got a young
secondary but they're playing well I'm
interested to see that matchup I think
that's you know that's that's going to
be the great matchup you know it's one
of the best brush defenses in the league
going against Todd Gurley and then the
Rams can stress you the same way the
Saints can with a run in the past and
then how does that secondary matchup
against the receivers for the Rams this
is Deion Sanders talking to three-time
Super Bowl champion Darryl moose Johnson
former Rich Eisen show filling in for my
humble host rich last but not least
who is your NFL MVP thus far I go with
Brees love you man I know everybody
likes mahomes you know people are
talking about early and those are guys
that are having a great year but I'm
always a fan of the body of work and one
of the things that we learned doing one
of our Saints games is the Drew Brees
has never been the league MVP he's been
runner-up three times I think it's two -
Manning - Rodgers and possibly to Gurley
last year but he's never won the league
MVP he's done everything else his body
of work throughout his career coming
back from that possible career-ending
injury and doing what he's done I I just
think it would be a shame I think the
consistency that he has shown throughout
his career you know what he is meant to
that Saints franchise it's funny when
people talk about the system in New
Orleans you know that well the system is
Drew Brees that's why it works here when
he leaves there's going to be a huge
transition into that next into that next
phase so I just think that the season
he's having right now if he continues on
this pace and and what he's done
throughout his career I really don't see
anybody else that you can give it to
besides Drew Brees Patrick mahomes is
having a great season it's his first
season as a starter I don't even know if
you know he has a season like this ever
again but but to me it's based on the
bodywork by Drew Brees in a 77% passion
completion percentage which is
unbelievable I mean one interception on
the year mm-hmm is unbelievable man it's
phenomenal it's a watchin play I mean he
raised eyebrows when he set the
completion percentage record last year
at what almost 72 and he's five
percentage points higher than that this
year it's amazing
III you know I've watched a good
quarterback play you know we got you and
I were blessed you know you could bless
to be around a number of good ones and
one our time in Dallas you know Troy was
considered
one of the most accurate passers yes in
the game at that time and to watch the
way the drew attacks the defense is
absolutely remarkable even working off
the standard that I'm used to with Troy
yeah this could be the NFC Championship
preview it really could be this weekend
and I'm excited I'm excited to see it
moves I love you man I appreciate you
you keep on dressing and doing what you
do you a treat to listen to your treat
to know your overall good dude and I'm
glad to say I play with moose Johnson
man glad to call you teammate look
forward to our lunch I got your man god
bless you moves you take the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience